we are less than our what less than a
few hours away now from election day
hundreds of thousands and vatins though
have already voted as the campaigns now
make their last pitches to those
undecided voters yeah poll 7 A.M to 7
P.M tomorrow 8 news now investigator
David charns here with why the campaigns
may be looking at previous elections and
the stakes ahead
what's really interesting about this
race is you have a governor who's now
running against a candidate for Senate
of course we have Adam laxalt run
against now Governor sisilak four years
ago and you can take a look at those
results and see how just close it was
now this was a good year for Democrats
basically a referendum on then president
Trump we had Governor sislock win that
race by four points but you can see by
all the red on the map Adam laxalt
actually did pretty well except here in
Clark County he got 41 percent of the
vote but compared to governor sicilak
who got 54 percent that's a 13 point
spread just shows how important Clark
County is to Democrats in winning this
race and what we've seen from the early
vote is that Democrats are ahead in that
early mail-in vote we know that
Democrats feel more secure with the
process and Republicans are more likely
to vote on Election Day we could do the
same thing for the election back in 2016
with now senator as masto and then
Congressman Joe heck this is in Washoe
County where the senator lost by just
about 1500 votes but again here in Clark
County she won by 11 points quickly want
to point out that there are other state
races that are important should a
governor Lombardo win or should Governor
sisalak get a second term we're talking
about the Senate and the State Assembly
Democrats have control of both
Republicans need just two seats in the
Senate they would have to get 11 seats
to win control over in the assembly
Democrats have 26 seats they would need
five seats to win control of course if
you have the party in control of the
legislature where it where it is the
assembly or the Senate and then the
party who is the governor if it's all
the same party that party can push a lot
more legislation through on their agenda
per another party so we'll just have to
wait and see what happens over the next
couple of days